well thank you so much hamesh it is
always a pleasure to be back in berkeley
uh you know i mean i mean uh the simon's
institute quantum program was actually
just about the last
uh trip that i took before covid started
you know and uh
i expected to be back there many more
times but you know i'm glad that i can
uh
be there virtually now and so um
you've probably all heard uh that a
couple of months ago
there was uh an announcement uh by a
team uh
at uh the ustc uh in in hefei china
um which is uh headed by uh chao yang
liu and jian mae pan
and they reported the the second
achievement
of quantum supremacy uh you know after
google's
uh they either they claimed it uh
claimed to uh
get uh get to uh sampling-based uh
quantum supremacy uh using boson
sampling okay which was uh
sort of maya and alex archipob's uh
original proposal for how to do that
uh back in 2011 and um
of course what what happened then was
that uh um
john martinez's team at google you know
around
2015 decided that they wanted to do
quantum supremacy based on sampling
but you know they were not going to do
boson sampling because that was just uh
uh
too uh too different from the
engineering design
that they uh that they were building so
they
uh said we're just going to build a
superconducting chip
you know with with uh such and such uh
specifications
and now we ask the theorists to adapt
the theory to do to this setting
and you know we basically said we accept
that challenge you know we can we we
uh uh we think we can do that and uh so
um you know um and then uh in
2019 so you know just shortly before
covet started uh the google team
announced that they'd achieved
quantum supremacy with uh their their uh
53 cubit chip uh sycamore you know that
claim uh has then you know been been
argued about and we can talk a little
bit about that
but you know i said at the time this is
important enough that
it requires replication right it
requires
you know seeing this with different
hardware platforms
with different experiments you know
because uh
you know it became clear that you know
as you look at you know all of these
things
much like with the bell inequality you
know experiments right there are always
you know loopholes if you want to push
hard enough you know on it
and you know different experiments will
have different loopholes
right so i did not at the time you know
regard quantum supremacy
as a done deal you know it was clear
that the google experiment was a huge
step forward
you know for the whole field uh but uh
you know even just
you know establishing the reality of
quantum supremacy
you know i felt like there was more more
to be done
so you know i was surprised and and
delighted
that uh this um team in china
actually went forward and and uh
you know took boson sampling up to the
scale of
you know 50 60 70 photons uh
that would that would be needed for for
quantum supremacy
uh now you know whether they've achieved
it or not is a is a hard question and
we'll and we'll uh
talk about that and it may depend on on
exactly what you mean
uh but it's clear that uh um you know
this
is this i mean i mean this is a a much
more impressive boson sampling
experiment that i than i would have
expected
uh could have been done uh at
at this time you know and after the
google thing i wasn't even sure that
anyone was going to still bother with
boson sampling
so you know i'm glad that people are but
you know what i want to do in this talk
is talk about the
you know just just review what boson
sampling is a little bit
and then talk about some of the
theoretical issues
um around boson sampling that we sort of
you know all of which are things that we
knew in the back of our minds
sort of could become relevant but now
that there is this uh
claim from the chinese group uh to have
actually achieved quantum supremacy
you know with uh those on boson sampling
some of these issues have been upgraded
to a really really pressing importance
and so i'm hoping to draw your attention
to these issues
and and i hope that at least some of you
will be inspired to think about them
okay so what is uh boson sampling okay
so
it's this proposal from you know me and
arkapov
in 2011 for this very rudimentary type
of quantum computer
where all you do is uh you generate
let's say n photons and they travel
through
m modes when we say m is large compared
to n
um a mode is just sort of a place where
a photon can be
okay so uh in quantum information terms
all we need to know
is that uh you know we have a
superposition in which each basis state
consists of a list of non-negative
integers okay so each basis state s
has the form s1 up to sm
where these s1 up to sm are
our non-negative integers summing up to
n
a and s sub i is just the number of
photons in the ith mode
okay so i i just think of them as like
balls in
identical balls that can you know you
have n of them and they can be
distributed
into m different bins okay so you know
it's a simple combinatorics problem to
say what is the dimension of the hilbert
space
or how many basis states are there and
it turns out to be m
plus n minus one choose n okay so in any
case if m and
n you know are both uh um
you know let's say uh growing together
then this is an x
there's an exponentially uh an
exponential number
of ways of distributing the photons into
the modes
okay now what can we do to our state
you know let's say we have some simple
initial state like
some of the modes have one photon and
others have zero photons
you know we think of that as our
standard initial state
we then apply some unitary
transformation
okay and the way that we do that is
using beam splitters
so we use a network of sort of optical
elements
you know sort of the optical version of
gates
but you know these are all gates that
act on two modes
at a time and you know and basically
this gives us a whole
bunch of simple matrices simple m by m
matrices that we multiply together
to give us an m by m uh what we would
call the mode
mixing unitary transformation u okay but
now
the the interesting part is that that
little unitary u
gives rise to a much bigger unitary
that acts on the hilbert space of n
photon states
right so so u this m by m unitary would
be enough if we just had a single photon
that was in a superposition of the modes
and we just wanted to know you know
what's going to happen to that
superposition
you know then we would just hit it with
that u okay but when we have n photon
states
then we have this much larger hilbert
space so what unitary is acting
on that much larger space well it's the
following one
okay i'll call it phi of u because you
know there's actually a homomorphism
uh from you know this little unitary u
to the big unitary fee of u and phi of u
is defined like this uh that you know if
i have two
basis states s and t then you know there
is a formula
for the s comma t entry of phi of u
and that formula involves the permanence
of n by n matrices okay this is the
connection
to the perm between linear optics and
the permanent function
okay and so here here is what i mean
so this by u s t i mean
uh an n by n matrix which we form
from our unitary matrix u by for each
i you know taking s sub i copies of the
i-th row of u
and then for each um j
taking t sub j copies of the jth column
okay so you know from our m by m matrix
we get an
n by n matrix uh i would call it a sub
matrix
except you know it may not be exactly
that because it may have repeated rows
or repeated columns
okay and then there's this normalization
factor
uh you know uh where you know i take the
square root of the products of the
factorials
of the essa buys and the these abides
okay and it's a magic fact
that once we do all of this uh you know
we actually
get a unitary transformation it's
unitary and it's a homomorphism
okay so uh you know there's be some
beautiful
mathematics there which you know uh uh
uh
alex and i learned from leonid girvitz
really and then we explained it all
in our boson sampling paper a decade ago
i mean all of it was known to the
physicists of course since the
since the 50s so uh
here here's an example just to fix ideas
okay let's say that we have the linear
optical
version of the hadamard transformation
okay so
that's just a single what's called a 50
50 beam splitter
so i've got two modes and let's say that
i put one photon in each mode
okay so uh so i send two
photons from opposite arms into this 50
50 beam splitter
and then i just look to see where the
photons emerge on the other end
and now you know physicists in the 80s
you know noted a a remarkable
fact about this which is that the beam
splitter somehow perfectly
correlates the two photons so in other
words
with half probability you will you know
if this experiment were done perfectly
you would see two photons emerge in the
top arm
in in this one here and with half
probability
you see two photons emerge in the bottom
arm here and you never see
the two photons go into two separate
arms you know even though this is sort
of just a beam splitter it's not
interacting the photons the photons are
never talking to each other
so how do they become correlated in this
way well we can see that if we just
apply the formula that i showed you
above so we can say what is the
matrix element you know if i take the
hadamard as my unitary
you know then what is the transition
amplitude to go from the basis state
one comma one it is you know one photon
in each mode
to itself and you know applying this
formula here
you find well it should just be the
permanent of the hadamard matrix
okay the permanent of the hadamard
matrix well i've got a negative
contribution here
i've got a positive contribution here
they cancel each other out
and it's zero okay so so there you know
there is a zero amplitude for that thing
to happen
this is the famous hongo mandel dip okay
and you know you uh for for the um
physicists i like to explain boson
sampling
as just the generalization of the hongo
mandel dip
from two photons to n photons
and from a fixed beam splitter network
to an
arbitrary beam splitter network you know
so that we
actually get a a computational problem
you know a uh
some some kind of you know and and
hopefully one that is exponentially hard
for classical computers all right
so let me make a few comments about uh
uh what you know the um the motivation
for boson sampling
okay so you know i think of it as a
rudimentary form of quantum computing
uh so you know we don't uh uh
expect it to be universal for quantum
computing or even for classical
computing for that matter
right i don't know how to do boolean
logic gates you know and
or xor you know using boson sampling you
know or
at least to to compose a whole bunch of
them okay so
uh so this is a very very special
you know model of computation um and yet
you know and
and uh you know the the quantum optics
people
had you know had an intuition that it
was clearly going to be useless
and you know in a sense you know they
you know as far as we know they
they still might be right right it might
indeed be useless
uh the point that we made is that you
know um
it might be doing something that is uh
useless but
hard to reproduce with a classical
computer okay
so uh you could say uh um um
uh so uh so so so what we did is simply
to say you know instead of
trying to shoehorn into this setup
some computational problem with a
definite right answer
let's just look at what this setup
intrinsically does
right and what it does is to sample from
a certain probability distribution okay
so
if you look at this beam splitter
network right what we can do with the
end of it
is we can just measure uh uh each
output mode and to see how many photons
there are in that mode
okay and typically we'll get a different
answer each time we do it
right because you know there are
exponentially many possible basis states
and really all we're doing is we're
sampling a random basis state
with probability equal to the absolute
square
of its amplitude okay so we are we are
sampling
okay and but because the amplitudes are
permanence
as you see from this formula because of
that
what we're doing is we are sampling from
a distribution
where the probabilities are squared
absolute values of permanence
of various n by n matrices okay and
you know and importantly these are
actually matrices of complex numbers
okay they're not just non-negative
matrices right which means you know
each one of these matrices you know if
you wanted to
even just estimate it's permanent then
as far as we know that is an exponential
computation right
there you know you have an exponential
number of terms
that mostly cancel each other out and
you know what determines
uh whether whether that outcome is
likely or unlikely
simply you know the size of the residue
that's left over after all of that
cancellation
right uh so you know that that seems
like a hard thing to
estimate now our original motivation
uh was you know that we we know in
classical cs
we we know a lot about the permanent you
know valiant famously showed in the late
70s
that the permanent is a sharp p complete
problem
meaning at least as hard as any
combinatorial counting problem um
and it was also uh realized in the 80s
and 90s
that the permanent has these properties
called random self-reducibility
self-correctability that sort of tell us
that the permanent is not only sharp
p complete but in some sense very
robustly so
okay and and and and and and we realized
that that uh
if you wanted sort of a robust
quantum supremacy experiment or in other
words you wanted to sample a
distribution
where even to approximate that
distribution with a classical computer
would be a hard problem
then then that was the kind of thing
that you were going to need
you're going to need uh to do some um
create some quantum state in which you
know the amplitudes
are sharp p complete you know and not
only that but they are sort of sharp p
complete even to approximate even to
approximate most of them
okay and and then we you know we just
you know i think i had heard some
some physicists tell me you want you
know that that this is what bosons do
so then i started you know we started
learning about bosons um
because you know just because we wanted
permanence into amplitudes
okay and so you know we were able to
prove some
formal hardness results for classical
simulation of boson sampling
you know which are still not as
satisfactory as we would really like
but you know an example of the kind of
result that we can show
uh is that you know so if you assume
that uh you know given a um
a a a random matrix so a matrix of just
independent gaussian entries they have
mean zero and variance one
uh that you know that to to
compute the permanent of that matrix you
know is not only is it hard
but it is sharp p hard even just to
approximate that permanent
you know even for most such matrices
okay that's a strong conjecture
but you know i think it's at least
plausible we said that you know if if
you could
uh believe that and you believe that the
polynomial hierarchy is infinite
then it follows that there is no
polynomial time
classical algorithm that can even sample
any distribution
that is say epsilon close to
the boson sampling distribution in in
total variation distance
where epsilon is some one over
polynomial yeah
in that okay and you know and this
result you know has been uh uh
um improved you know i think actually
i'm
adam uh you and others you know had a
paper just this week
on the archive uh tightening this result
in some respects so
you know there's lots of research that
continues you know really what i would
love
is to just you know remove this
assumption i would love to say that
boson sampling is classically hard
solely
under the assumption that the polynomial
hierarchy is infinite or some other
standard complexity assumption
okay but that you know we knew was a
hard problem 10 years ago
it remains a seemingly very hard problem
today
um and you know now uh uh
what you know i mean for all the effort
that we spent on this
you know what um um what what what
happened
in the last decade is that you know the
experimentalists you know got a hold of
this right and by the way
sort of you know i i can know i i i'm
these days i can barely follow the
literature on boson sampling
right now that the now now now that uh
uh
you know the the uh physicists have
taken over the subject to such an extent
and sort of you know uh uh remade it you
know uh
and you know so they um you know the you
know as as
as as far as we had to stick our necks
out
you know for uh uh you know to in order
to get the conclusion that sort of boson
sampling is hard
it is nothing compared to how far you
know you have to stick your necks out
for the variance of boson sampling that
you know interest the experimentalists
because you know those are the ones that
sort of they can actually implement in
the lab
okay so you know what what we've seen in
the last decade
is this sort of interplay that i think
you know is very characteristic of our
field
uh which is that the you know the
experimentalists will take hold of a
theoretical idea
but they can't exactly realize it okay
they can only realize
some variation of it and then that
itself
gives rise to a new theoretical question
right
you know the question is can we as
theorists sort of meet the
experimentalists in the middle
okay can we get something where you know
we are still
you know as as roughly you know
confident about hardness
as we were for you know the original
proposal
but you know which is some you know uh
uh
uh but but that they can actually
implement okay
so you know so that's kind of been the
discussion over the last decade
and yes um seth
landau is asking what do you mean by
approximation
i'm guessing he's asking do you mean
additive multiplicative oh
yeah what i mean there is um um
i'm comparing probability distributions
by their total variation distance
right so i think that's that's the sort
of empirically relevant way to compare
them
right you know if if if you say that the
classical algorithm only has to
um or if you say the classical algorithm
has to
have a good multiplicative approximation
then we know how to get a very strong
hardness result right then we
know how to say that you know it's hard
to do that for a classical computer
you know under the sole assumption that
you know p
to the sharp p is is not in the the
polynomial hierarchy
okay but um the trouble
is that that's just not the physically
relevant you know setting right i mean
you know even the experiment itself you
know
under the best conditions you could hope
that it will do
something that is close in variation
distance
to the you know to the true ideal
distribution
and so it seems unfair to require that a
classical simulation
of your experiment do anything better
than that
okay good so here is a very condensed
history
of the experiments that have you know
tried to realize boson sampling okay so
uh um you know uh uh so you know just
shortly after our proposal came out you
know optics people
said well you know we could we could
actually do this
uh you know but you know at first it was
very extremely far from the regime of
quantum supremacy
so the first experiment in australia
um was with three photons you know it
verified that the indeed
the probabilities of the the outputs you
know go
like the squares of three by three
permanence
but you know which is a good sanity
check but you know a classical computer
can also calculate three by three
permanents
uh then um a group in in bristol which
is now sort of moved and is now the
company
sai quantum in palo alto but at that
time they were still at a university of
bristol
uh they managed to push things up to uh
six
photons um and then um
uh you know uh not much happened for for
a few years but then a year ago around
the same time as google's announcement
the group of um
pan and lou at ustc uh reported that
they they had done boson sampling
with uh 14 photons detected i think they
they send in about 20 and they generate
four
and then they detect 14 at the detector
so so let's call it 14.
you know and and and and that chao yang
liu
told me at the time uh uh you know we
we intend to push forward and go all the
way to quantum supremacy
and i was like okay you know that's nice
you know i uh
you know i mean you know you know in
order to be experimentalists you know
you have to be someone who you know
talks a big game and you know whatever
believe it when i say it
uh and then just uh um
um um a few months ago they came out
with a paper
uh in science where they've reported
that
that that they did it they built if you
see a photo of it you know this
gargantuan optical table uh
and you know they are able to detect you
know
on average about 50 to 70 photons
and um you know they've tried to
simulate this with classical computing
and you know they run out you know i
mean the the
the best classical algorithms that they
know uh
um um you know using the biggest
supercomputer that they have available
to them
uh right you know uh reaches its limit
at about 40 photons
i actually asked them to do the 40
photon experiment
and they wrote back and said okay we've
done it but but we just that just costed
us half a million dollars of computer
time
so we're not going to go further than
that so that was like the most
uh exp uh inadvertently expensive
refereeing i ever did
okay but um uh now
uh uh as uh uh the ustc group pointed
out
their experiment actually has one big
advantage
compared to the google experiment and
this
is that they're dealing with a much much
larger number of different possible
outputs
okay so you know because they have about
a hundred
in addition to 50 or 70 photons they
have a hundred modes
and so if you work it out they have got
about 10 to the 30th
possible outputs of their experiment
compared to google's
which had two to the 53 power possible
outputs which is about
10 to the 16 about uh 10 quadrillion
okay so uh why do we care about that
that difference
here uh well um you know mainly because
of this
um rebuttal that ibm uh published
to to google's quantum supremacy claim
if you recall
what ibm said was well if you
you know took the literally largest
supercomputer on the planet
uh you know the summit at a oak ridge
national lab
then you know it actually has enough
hard disk space
to store 10 to the 16 amplitudes in it
okay and so you could just do a naive
matrix vector multiplication to simulate
the uh uh google's chip and you know
you know we can't actually get access to
this machine but
if we could then we think it would only
take us a few days
okay uh to simulate what the google chip
did in a
few minutes so you know so so so the
google chip
is still faster for the quantum
supremacy task
but you know it's not it's not that
simulating it would take 10 000 years
as google originally estimated with with
uh with with current
classical computing okay now uh uh
that kind of brute force attack you know
is not going to work with
any currently existing super computer if
instead of 10 to the 16
uh uh parameters you've got 10 to the
30th of
them right so like if you imagine that
you just keep
taking samples over and over and over
again uh from your boson sampling chip
then you know in order to keep up with
that uh um
with with a classical simulation what
you would want is basically to
pre-compute the entire distribution
and you know but pre-computing the whole
distribution is not going to work
if you can't even fit the whole
distribution in any
in any hard disk that that now exists
okay so so there's this you know some
advantage there
even if calculating one specific
amplitude
is you know of roughly comparable
hardness to what it was with with
google's experiment
so we have a question from the uh
panelist uh
umar ahmed uh the dummy who asked why
would one want to store
amplitude data instead of other parts of
the wave function
uh well what i mean what what other i
mean a wave function is a collection of
amplitudes
i mean how how would you propose to
store it
uh i'm i'm not entirely sure um
you could ask you know find them paths
or things like this right well yeah yeah
well you can
you know simulate a quantum computation
by doing fineman paths
the issue with that is that um well
you know the the issues are are you know
um first of all
if it's with quantum circuits then the
time needed goes exponentially with the
number of gates
which could be a lot worse than
exponential in the number of qubits
but secondly a fineman path only give
you know doing a fineman summation only
gives you one specific amplitude
okay so if you need to simulate a whole
bunch
you know billions of samples then uh
then
it quickly becomes infeasible right and
you know what you would want is to get
the amortized advantage
from calculating all of the amplitudes
in one go
okay that is the kind of thing that you
could do with an ibm
style you know brute force simulation
that wrote down all the amplitudes
but that's not going to work if there's
10 to 30 of them
thanks sure okay
now i want to discuss uh some of you
know the
the the issues uh that um um
have come to the fore you know and um
people have
you know the uh uh you know as as as
expected
you know the claim from ustc sort of
sparked the whole
discussion online with uh people you
know trying to uh
kill the claim of quantum supremacy uh
one of the big ironies here
is that you know among the people who
are trying to refute
the ustc quantum supremacy claim
are you know gil collide you know the
you know a quantum computing skeptic not
surprisingly
also the google team okay and and gil
was actually you know uh
working together with the google team to
you know try to uh
uh poke holes in the ustc experiment
so you know it's a um strain you know
um quantum supremacy makes strange
bedfellows i guess
uh but uh you know i think that this is
exactly what
should happen people should take you
know the the uh
uh um uh you know should take
as hard as swing at this you know as
they can because you know ultimately we
are only confident
in a claim of quantum supremacy if it
still stands
you know after people have tried as hard
as possible to refute it
it's a lot like uh applied cryptography
in that respect
okay so now uh in the rest of this talk
i want to go through
you know a few of the issues that have
come come to the fore okay
well first issue is just you know um how
many modes
do we have uh um you know and then what
what is the relevance of
m the number of modes so you know for
for a long time
uh the you know for four years after we
came out with the boson sampling
proposal
uh experimentalists kept hoping that
they could make
boson sampling harder for a classical
computer
just by increasing the number of modes
okay
they hope that the difficulty of
simulating it would scale like
m to the n power because you know that
is how many basis states there are right
if i wanted to calculate the entire
distribution
then i would need like m to the n time
um and yeah and and and and you know we
we we couldn't prove that there was a
better classical simulation than that
but i kept telling them based on
complexity theory
the most that you can assume is that you
have hardness that goes like two to the
n
n being a number of photons okay a few
years ago
that intuition was actually put on a
firm footed
by a beautiful result of clifford and
clifford
who showed how you can take a boson
sampling experiment
and classically simulate it in only two
to the end time
okay so so indeed you know the the get
having more modes
you know doesn't really help in that
respect
but having as far as we know having too
few modes could hurt you
okay so if you look at mayan archipop's
theoretical analysis
we we had to assume uh for a tech
for a technical reason um
that uh that the number of modes m was
uh
was at least uh the square was large
compared to the number of photons
squared
okay and and the reason for this is
basically the birthday paradox
okay we wanted to avoid photons bunching
together into the same mode
that was just you know inconvenient for
our analysis
uh now this assumption is typically not
satisfied
by by any of the the boson sampling
experiments right
they may you know as you saw the ustc
experiment
has like 50 photons a hundred minutes
right so they take
maybe you know maybe m equals two n or
something like that
um now my guess would be that that's not
such a big issue
okay you have if so it means you have a
few you know photon collisions here and
there
but but the you know the permanence
should retain
their hardness but it would be nice to
have a theoretical analysis
uh supporting that intuition okay so
that's
that's that that that's one issue i
think that we were already aware of you
know seven or eight years ago but you
know it could
it could it would it would benefit from
from uh from more theoretical analysis
what happens when m is linear in n
okay now uh let me move on uh to a
bigger issue
and this issue is about the initial
state
okay so in our paper um um
archipov and i assume you know the
initial state
to be this very very simple thing what
the physicists would call a fox state
okay and and this is uh i just in the
let's say the first
n modes i have one photon in each of
them exactly one photon
and i have zero photons in any of the
other myths
okay so boson sampling with with that as
the initial state
uh is is now called fbs
for foc boson sampling or aabs
for you know aarons and arkapuff okay
and that's contrasted
with the you know the the now in vogue
kinds of boson sampling that all that
i'll tell you about shortly okay
the problem is that uh uh basically
we we still don't know how to produce a
determin
a single photon deterministically on
demand
uh in the lab okay there does not on
earth
you know exist a a photon source that
can do that
um what there are is you know there are
lasers
which make things that are called
coherent states
coherent state is a certain kind of
superposition
over different possible numbers of
photons okay
and um in addition to those coherent
states
you can make um other kinds of
superpositions of different numbers of
photons
in particular there's this thing called
a two mode squeezed
state and i wrote a formula for it here
it's basically just a super
you know sum over all possible numbers
of photons n
from zero up to infinity of you know n n
so you know um n photons in each of two
modes
and the amplitude for having n photons
in in each of the modes
goes down exponentially
that's a that's a two mode squeeze state
and you can make
this kind of thing uh using uh standard
lab equipment
like something called a spontaneous
parametric down converter
an spdc source okay and
you know the this two most two mode
squeeze state is just one special case
of a more general type of uh state that
is
uh very very uh well known and then
studied by the quantum optics people
called a gaussian state okay and a
gaussian state you know it's if i had to
if i have to write it like this
in the photon number basis you know then
it's a little bit messy to define what
they are
it's easier to define them as just you
know um
um you know in terms of the creation and
annihilation operators
right but uh it's it's basically ones
where they the
uh uh you take a a quadratic polynomial
of
creation operators okay so you know
gaussian states are this particularly
experimentally accessible class of
quantum states
and so one of the very first questions
that the experimentalists
asked me and alex was well what if your
inputs are gaussian states instead of
fox states
you know is boson sampling still a hard
problem for a classical computer
right and we didn't know okay it was
clear that
you know if they're coherent states you
know so standard laser light
then it's easy to simulate with a
classical computer and that was a
a well-known fact okay but but if if
they were gaussian states uh we didn't
know
uh then actually some of the
experimentalists
came up with the key idea in 2013.
um all i did was i invented a name for
the id for their idea and i blogged
about it
okay i called it scattershot boson
sampling
so it's now called sbs
and the idea here is you know you you
make a two mode squeeze state
but with a value of c which is very
close to zero
okay so now i have these um these states
but like like
if there's a photon at all then all
almost
all of the the the amplitude is on just
one photon here
and one photon here right and then
basically what you can do is you can
reduce to the case of ordinary boson
sampling this way
okay and the trick is that
you you you use all you know you you
have a whole bunch of modes or a whole
bunch of pairs of modes
where you generate these two mode
squeeze states and then we have a whole
bunch of
photon detectors over here that are
looking for where is there one photon
and wherever there happens to be one
photon over here
then automatically we know that there is
also one photon over the
over here in the in the partner mode
right and then whichever
you know so we don't control which of
these modes will happen to have a photon
in them
but whichever ones do we can simply
define those
as the initial state for our foc boson
sampling experiment
and it will be just as good as any other
initial state would have been
you know for this purpose okay so that's
the basic intuition
one can actually prove formally that you
know assuming that
focus on sampling is hard to
approximately simulate by a classical
computer
then so is this scatter shot boson
sampling
okay so so it sort of it preserves the
the prop
the original hardness of the problem
okay now
the the trouble is from the
experimentalist point of view
you know this is still very wasteful
like you're still wasting
a huge number of modes and they didn't
really want to do that
okay so partly for that reason um
um some of the uh mixed
physicists and hamilton at all um and uh
christine silverhorn and some others uh
uh you know uh um published a more
general proposal
what's now called gauss what they call
gaussian boson sampling or
gbs and um and this is just where where
the input could be
an arbitrary gaussian state doesn't have
you know and you think of it as just
like
a random gaussian state okay uh
so so the randomness instead of it being
in the beam splitter network it's sort
of
you know or we did we put it into the
you know what
what we would have thought of as the
initial state okay so
uh um so uh
so so and and actually um the the
boson sampling experiments that are now
done seem to be almost all be
this gbs gaussian boson sample okay now
it turns out you know a a a key result
in this hamilton at all paper is that
if you look at the probabilities of the
various outcomes
in a gbs experiment uh they're they're
not given by
the absolute squares of permanence
instead they're given by a different
function of a matrix which is called the
hafnia
okay a little bit more exotic function
uh so basically uh um for you know
like if i have a you know you could
think of the permanent
as a function that counts the number of
perfect matchings
in a bipartite graph right the hafnian
is a function that counts the number of
matchings
in a general graph okay and so
so you know these hafnians are are what
arise
when you look at the output
probabilities uh in
in gaussian boson sampling you know the
half theon
is also sharp p complete okay so that's
the good news
um you know the bad news is that no one
has really done
a theoretical analysis of galaxy and
boson sampling
uh at the same like level of care
you know as as was done for for foxboson
sampling
okay and then you know sorry uh sorry uh
uh scott uh yeah so so do you do you
have a
do you have a nice way to think about
these gaussian states
outside of uh you know creation and
inhalation operators so
how would you um
yeah i mean i could write down a formula
later i mean i mean
i mean vaguely i just think about them
as things like this thing
uh you know so they are um
uh so so so so basically you know we
we take um um you know
e to the power of you know some
polynomial and the creation operators
right
and and you know and that that's going
to be a
a quadratic so uh
we um um
[Music]
yeah i mean you know this is this yeah i
mean i mean but but but like like
aside from writing down that formula you
know which which i could do for you if
you you wanted me to
i don't you know the the yeah maybe i
should put this as an additional problem
like come up with a more tcs friendly
way to think about gaussian states
right so in terms of yours the scatter
shot goes on sampling that was
that was pretty straightforward right
that yeah your input is
is is uh is runs on some subset of
of your of your uh input wires well yes
well the input state actually is a
gaussian state it is something like this
but then the key point there was that we
could reduce to the case of focus on
sampling
right and now you know so so you could
say that like
there you're you know you're sort of you
know staying in the like the safe end of
the pool
or something you know and and what the
physicists now want to do is like jump
into the dangerous end right to just
just use
you know a random gaussian state where
we don't have the same kind of
theoretical analysis but where you're
you're taking full fuller advantage of
all the degrees of freedom that you've
got in your experiments
so so and it's not okay to think of the
input as being
on at each of these buyers as being
being some gaussian distributed number
of bozo
the issue is that they can be correlated
with each other right so
there are there are correlations between
the modes but it is actually it is
actually a multivariate gaussian
so there's there's a multivariate
gaussian
and is that is that exact so can you
actually
uh you know is it is it is it correct to
think of it as a
multivariate gaussian well it's sorry
it's it's
uh it's gaussian sorry it's gaussian if
you look at the vigner function
representation
if you look if no if you look at if you
look at photon numbers
then you get you know uh um
you know you i mean i mean you know you
get these these you know
formulas that you know that all that'll
be like like this you know they'll
involve
exponentials but more more complicated
than that
okay sorry so can i add a little comment
to this so in quantum optics
um the gaussian name i mean it comes
i mean you can see the connection if you
just transform your
creation and annihilation operators to
x and p type operators and then you
represent it in face space and then
then in the gaussian nature appears very
naturally yeah that that
was good brigitte i mean i think that's
exactly i think that's just what i was
saying
right yeah i think that's that's the
best way to think about the gamer
representation
and then as you see the the width of the
gaussian then that brings in
though this gaussian increases in width
and you're bringing in larger photon
numbers
yeah but you know i i would love to have
a more tcs friendly
picture right like again i feel like i
was comfortable with
foxbows on sampling in a way that you
know i am less comfortable with gbs
and that that might just be me right
that might not be anything intrinsic to
these well your
your two most squeeze state is basically
single photons in disguise because
you're talking about photon pairs and
that's
so and you're detecting one that's right
that's right no i mean i mean so you
have heralded single photons there
no no no i think you're you're right so
i mean again with
scatter shot bows on sampling there i'm
still comfortable because there we can
reduce to the case that we already
understand
right but but the recent and in
particular the ustc experiment
they take gaussian states into a regime
where we don't have such a reduction
okay that that uh that was my point
now you know my guess would be that one
can do you know a hardness analysis
that is tailored to you know to to to
this setting
you know to haftnian's instead of
permanence and it will go through
more or less the same but that is
another challenge that is another thing
that that you know someone needs to do
um now an additional issue
with the uh ustc experiment uh was that
uh
they don't actually have uh detectors
that can
count the number of photons in each mode
okay what they have are
detectors that can just tell you is
there at least one photon
in this mode right so they give you
cruder information
and so so then the probabilities of the
possible outputs of those kinds of
detectors
are actually sums over exponentially
many different
afnians and uh the uh
um um a group based in toronto
had a paper a couple of years ago where
they called these torontonians so
that's the that's the that's the term
that that they use and they're in the
usdc group uses in their science paper
they talk about torontonians okay
so uh i would like to move on now uh how
much time do i have in this
certainly 10 minutes 10 minutes all
right that that
that that that should be enough so you
know there were there were two other
issues that i wanted to discuss
you know now a really important issue is
photon losses
okay so again exp you know early on the
experimentalist pointed out to us
you know that you know you send photons
through your network of beam splitters
you know you will not always detect them
at the other end right sometimes they'll
get lost
by the way you know it's it's funny that
just the same issue
you know be deviled the uh experiments
to violate the bell inequality
right for for for decades okay so here
again you've got the issue of photon was
uh mocking up your quantum supremacy
demonstration
uh so you know so could it be that once
a few photons get lost
then the resulting distribution is
somehow easy for a classical computer to
simulate
well so daniel brode and i looked at
this question
in 2016 and we were able to show
that if out of your end photons only a
constant number of them get lost
then uh foc boson sampling retains its
original hardness
you know at least at least in in an
asymptotic sense
okay no this was not very satisfactory
because in real life you're going to
lose more than
than o of one photons okay and so then
you know that left the question of what
happens when when more get lost
uh and so you know the um you know i
think that you know some of
the best results uh on this are from uh
jelmer renima
and um valerie skesnovich and uh well
garcia petrone you know they had a paper
about this
just a year or two ago where they say
basically
that uh you know if a constant fraction
of the photons are getting lost
then you know depending on that fraction
you know for
foc boson sampling there should be an
asymptotically efficient classical
simulation
okay now you know that might sound like
this is completely fatal
for boson sampling experiments okay um i
don't think so
okay uh what i think it's telling us
is that uh like i i think it's telling
us something that we should have
expected from the very beginning
namely that you know if you have divide
you know
components with a constant rate of noise
then
you cannot build a scalable quantum
computer out of them
unless you do some sort of error
correction
right so you know it is it is sort of
the analog
of say you know another fact that's
known which is that
if i have a random quantum circuit and
all of my gates are noisy
then you know asymptotically you know
this can be efficiently simulated
classically
right there's um uh um
[Music]
um uh um i'm looming uh i'm i'm sorry
i'm blanking on the names but there
there was a paper a few years ago um you
know showing that
for for for for random circuits okay
uh you know now the point with a
supremacy experiment
like google's is that as long as your
noise rate is small
compared to the scale of your experiment
then you can still extract
a signal whereas a classical computer
still needs time that is sort of
exponential
in the scale of your experiment right so
you can still eke out a win
you know even in this era before we have
quantum fault tolerance
and i would i would argue that precisely
the same is true with boson sampling
right the question you know it's like it
comes down to numbers in the end
right um you know like with this rate of
loss
you know sort of uh um can you actually
simulate the experiment
efficiently in practice let's say you
know with 50 photons or whatever
or will you you know basically see
notice the exponentiality
you know the 2 to the 50th type of
behavior you know despite the loss
when you try to simulate with a
classical computer so that's a more
detailed question
and you know we still don't really know
the answer
uh the um what what is worrying
is that if you look at the rate of loss
in the ustc experiment
about 70 of the photons are getting lost
okay and you know that you have to read
between the lines of the paper
to see that but we've confirmed that
with the chao yang liu
and so i think it's it is plausible that
they're in a regime
where there is an efficient classical
simulation but on the other hand
no one has managed to show that either
okay
no one has managed to show how to
reproduce what they're
doing in any reasonable amount of time
uh
there is a connection i should say to a
uh
a theory paper that um gilco i and guy
kinsler wrote
six years ago where they said you know
like here is the you know at but at the
time looked like a very artificial noise
model
but under that noise model they said you
know boson sampling becomes
asymptotically easy to approximately
simulate
like there's like a hierarchy uh where
like they
had to do the kth level of their
hierarchy would take like n to the k
time and you know and when you add some
noise then for reasons of for your
analysis
basically a constant value of k starts
to suffice and so i start
being able to simulate a boson sampling
experiment classically an
n to the o of one time um you know and
it turned out that that actually uh um
what kawaii and kindler were talking
about is actually a reasonable model
for that for the kind of noise that
arises physically although
although that was only shown later okay
um just you know i want i want to give
gil uh a credit where it's due
okay so uh you know now now the final
issue uh is about the verification
of the results okay now how you know how
do you
once you've done one of these sampling
based quantum supremacy experiments
uh how do you actually know what you've
done how do you verify the answer
right and you know and like we you know
this was an issue that
arkapov and i did not give nearly enough
attention a decade ago
okay uh you know i mean we we we we
we've tried to remedy that since
uh as of other people but uh now what
what google did with its experiment last
year its random circuit sampling
experiment
was you know they computed a certain
quality measure for the samples that
they saw
which they called the linear cross
entropy benchmark
or lxeb okay and the way it worked
was that you know they took all of the
samples that they generated
uh and then you know they they just
calculated
uh for each sample what what would be
the ideal probability
of the circuit generating that sample
that's this thing here
and then they just sum them all up okay
multiply by a normalizing factor
okay now here's what one can show if you
were just guessing the s sub is
uniformly at random then you would
expect
a linear cross entropy score of exactly
one okay
if you had a perfect quantum computer
that sampled precisely from the output
distribution
of your random quantum circuit c then
you would expect a linear cross entropy
score
of precisely two or you know extremely
close to two
okay um now google in its experiment
reported a linear cross entropy score
of 1.002 okay
so very far from the ideal very noisy
but they took enough samples that they
could really really prove
you know to uh like with ten sigmas or
twenty sigmas or you know
extreme confidence that this 1.002
really is greater than one
okay so you know and and and now um
you know some theoretical results
suggest that that is already
enough for quantum supremacy so
for example sam gunn um uh
i just uh saw you know the um um
they're there at berkeley uh when he was
an undergrad uh uh here at ut
austin he and i um had a paper saying
that
uh um you know any classical algorithm
you know if if you wanted it to achieve
a linear cross entropy score
which is bounded above one um you know
in fact you know even
even exponentially you know even like
one plus
you know c to the minus n right you know
even slightly better than one
uh then um you know you know either your
classical algorithm
needs exponential time to do that or
else it can actually
like estimate amplitudes in a random
quantum circuit
better than the trivial estimator can
okay so you know
you get some some unlikely consequence
of course we would like better
evidence for hardness but but at least
at least we had
something okay and now the point that i
want to make
is that in the case of boson sampling
we lack even a picture that
that is that clear okay we lack even the
kind of evidence that
sam gunn and i or or earlier uh luigi
chan and i
uh had had for a random circuit sampling
okay and the basic reason for that
is that in the case of boson sampling
sort of
you know one one classical algorithms
really can do better
and just you know completely naive
guessing
okay a classical algorithm really does
know something more
than just you know every every output
you know is about as likely as every
other one
okay so uh so for example um arkapov and
i had a paper in 2013
called boson sampling is far from
uniform
and what we showed there is that you
know given an n by n matrix
x uh in polynomial time you can easily
produce
some at you know number that is a little
bit correlated with the permanent of
that matrix
right just by for example taking the
product of the norms of all the rows
there's something as stupid as that okay
but you know it's not a very good
approximation to the permanent but it's
non-trivially correlated with the
permanent
okay so it already achieved something
like a
you know a and a non-trivial estimate of
the output probabilities
that we don't think would have been
possible for random circuit sampling
okay so that's a difference between the
two problems
um also leonid girvitz had an important
result where he showed that
if you take a boson sampling experiment
and i just want to know the marginal
distribution over
any k modes then i can compute that
classically
in time n to the o of k okay like n to
the 2k
i think okay so and and and these you
know k mode marginals are not completely
uniform
they have little fluctuations in them
that i can you know verify
so what this means is that if i take any
of these i you know i could
take an analog of this linear cross
entropy score
and in fact the ustc team did do that
they did calculate a linear
cross-entropy score
they did show that they achieved a
higher value
for their experiment than you know like
the simplest classical estimators would
have achieved
that was the basis for their quantum
supremacy claim
the problem is that for boson sampling
we know that there are
these non-trivial classical estimators
you know like they're there you know and
in fact there's this whole hierarchy
that kawaii and kindler proposed
where you know the ks level takes n to
the k time to compute
and we don't yet know at what level of
that hierarchy are you going to like
beat the results
of the ustc experiment um gelmar renama
and others are working on that and i
eagerly
await uh news from them about about what
is going on there
okay so you know there are lots of other
exciting problems i mean one of the
biggest ones
is you know is there a uh way to
efficiently verify
the outcome of a boson sampling
experiment like some cryptographic
scheme
you know something along the lines of
what uh irma mahadev
you know did but that we could actually
implement
you know in the near future you know
with uh with
with like near-term boson sampling
hardware where we could actually
see you know we don't have to do
arbitrary computations but just that
something classically hard is being done
i think you know that's maybe one of the
biggest problems
and of course are there any applications
of boson sampling
you know several were proposed uh for
um something called vibronic spectra in
chemistry
for uh finding a dense subgraphs of a
graph
i'm not really persuaded by any of those
applications
that you're really beating what
classical algorithms could do
okay but you know it's possible that
there's some application that could be
found
if nothing else then maybe generating
certified random bits
okay but you know but that would require
an analysis
right because as we saw there are
differences between
boson sampling and random circuit
sampling
and you know with boson sampling
classical algorithms
do have at least a little bit of a
toehold and it remains to figure out
just how much of a dough hold they have
all right so let me stop there and i
thank you for listening
great uh thanks scott that was that was
fantastic
um that was uh i think that was the kind
of talk we've been
uh wanting in this colloquium
it was in the in the spirit that you
said that you can barely follow what's
happening in the field so
you know this this notion that even
experts are having trouble keeping track
of
everything that's happening and uh you
know trying to declutter it this was
fantastic
well so i'm really glad if my confusion
came through
great so um well we should um
let's um let's um
do questions here and then okay
afterwards um
scott can you stay uh at gather town for
a little bit um i can
yeah i can okay great i'll i'll put the
gather town link in there
in the chat and the q a thanks anyone
who wants to join
so um
yeah i i should say that uh yeah sorry
finding the urls for zooms and gather
towns has been the bane of my existence
yes um okay so uh
adam goland and and chin men air care
have been uh
moderating this so so you know if you
have if you're
if you can find any questions please
yeah we have a question from an
anonymous attendee
who asks uh something like well if we
never expected noisy
quantum supremacy experiments to have
asymptotic hardness
then to what extent have these
experiments challenge the quantum
extended church turing thesis or
or could they in the future well
i mean i i would say that uh um
you know uh um you know so so
let's look at google's experiment for
example right
so you know they they have a device with
53 cubits
you know it is you know noisy but not
so noisy that they weren't able to
extract a signal from it
right so they extracted you know you
know
a signal at like the point two percent
level right
you know which took a few million
samples which you know
at the given the speed of the the their
device they were able to do
in a few minutes um and now you know
this this signal that they you know
extracted
you know uh um above this noise uh
is something that as far as we know to
reproduce it with a classical computer
you know you you need something like 2
to the 53 time
right that's about nine quadrillion uh
and you know and
and even you know all of the uh papers
that have come
out since you know they sort of you know
they they've they haven't challenged
that sort of fundamental
exponentiality right nothing has sort of
broken the two to the end barrier you
know they've they've sort of
uh shown that you know things are a
thing you know you you can get
sort of down to that two to the end you
can sort of shave off the
the the fat that's you know above that
but but nothing is sort of
you know all of the simulations that we
know whether they're feinman
or schrodinger type simulations or
tensor network methods
they you know they all involve some kind
of brute force
some kind of exponentiality and now we
could ask
why is that right why are
all the classical simulations needing
you know nine quadrillion steps
to simulate what the machine you know
what what the what the chip itself
did with only a few thousand you know
elementary operations
and the only explanation for that that i
know
is well because of the exponentiality of
the wave function
right because you know the the
exponentiality of quantum states
was successfully harnessed to you know
for for a computational end
okay and if that is true then i would
say that
you know the scalability of quantum
computing has not yet been established
right the possibility of quantum error
correction
uh has not yet you know been uh or uni
um you know error correction for
universal
scalable quantum computers has not yet
been established but
you know at least one of the main
contentions
of quantum computing theory has has now
been established
in a way that it wasn't previously right
that you could have a programmable
device
that actually you know harnesses the
exponentiality
of a quantum state to do some
well-defined task
right that is still true even in the
presence of noise
and and i and i do think that that moves
the conversation forward
you know i think that that does you know
and and and if you don't believe me
you could believe gil collide right gil
you know has been you know extremely
vocal and saying that if
this experiment you know you know uh is
upheld if
if if it was really done correctly the
google one
then it already refutes his entire
worldview
right you know that he firmly predicts
that no such experiment is possible
now the conclusion he draws is that
there must be some mistake in
you know the analysis of the google
experiment even if
you know neither he nor anyone else has
figured out yet what it is
okay so you know you have to you know
give him credit for you know the uh
the the uh um um you know
uh carriage of his of his convictions
right but
but you know that that is the position
that that he takes right
he is not saying oh it doesn't count
because it's noisy or it's not scalable
he is saying no you know i i conjectured
that you would never
exploit the exponentiality of quantum
states
to outperform a classical computer if
this is true then this refutes that
so we have uh another question um which
is going back to some of these
algorithms like the kali kindler
algorithm yeah what
uh linear cross entropy score do these
non-trivial classical algorithms yield
um so so i don't
actually remember that a delta retima
would be the best person that will get
his right
and this is one of the main problems
that like it is
you know um i i i don't feel like i have
the level of clarity
that i had you know with with random
circuit sampling right
so first of all you know they look at a
measure that is not
you know exactly you know linear cross
entropy i think they actually just look
at
you know ordinary uh a non-linearized
cross-entropy
okay which you know fine you can you can
do that
and then um the last that i heard from
um from chao yang uh was that they had
done an analysis
where you know first of all if you know
if you just
you know um you know took
knowledge of the beam splitter network
but you assumed
the photons were behaving as classical
particles
you know just classical distinguishable
particles
then that would give rise to an xcb
score
that is you know very much smaller than
this than the score that they found
and and then they also said if you if
you do something that spoofs the two
mode marginals correctly
then that also leads to a score that is
smaller than the score they found
and if you pretend that the photons were
acting like thermal states
then that leads to a score that's
smaller than the score that they found
uh but you know of course that that
that's very far from exhausting
the whole space of spoofing strategies
right
you know i am personally not satisfied
with you know a an analysis that just
says well
you know we we thought of a few
potential spoofing attacks and we ruled
those out
right i would like to do better than
that um
and and and i would like to have
everything plotted on one scale
and show you some clear numbers um i
actually
i actually wrote to to gelmer renima to
ask him for
for an update he hasn't written back yet
but if i
uh um you know well if if if
when when i do learn any anything
materially new
i'll probably put it on my blog so you
can find it there
uh umesh shall we do the rest of the
questions on gather
i i think that would be that would be
fine yes
okay yeah so uh so thank
thanks scott again for a great seminar
and thanks everybody for attending
so see you all at gathertown all right
we'll see you there
uh let's let me find that url before it
goes away
here
all right see you there great bye